bored now so last time I talked about
Buffy I gave you what I thought were the
10 best episodes of Buffy the Vampire
Slayer and I got to be fair I got to
look at the other side of the coin and
take a look at the worst episodes of
Buffy the Vampire Slayer and this list
for how long Buffy was on how many
episodes it had did not have as many
contenders as one might think
it's not to say the show was always
perfect it had its weak moments it had
its weak seasons but truly bad episodes
at least in my estimation are few and
far between
I do have 10 here to talk about those so
let's get to it with number 10 I Robot
you Jane
so this is an episode that just sort of
shows some of the initial growing pains
of the the show as a whole I think the
whole thing with willow kind of falling
in love online with a beard demon thing
and and then it gets a robot body if it
there's some not altogether
uninteresting gods that send this like
the idea of ancient beings getting
caught up and integrated in newer
technology things that didn't exist when
you know they were around before is
there's possibilities there but I think
in many ways this is one of the episodes
that really I don't think was great at
the time but it's aged very poorly just
with the way in which people talk about
how the internet works in in and it's
sort of stoking the fires of the fear of
what you know some what some stranger
online could get you to do and it just
it's one of the things that results when
you try and be topical but you don't
really have anything of substance to say
it's the episode just kind of
regurgitated the generic fears of the
time and I mean I the show as a whole
got a lot of mileage out of taking real
world high school age concerns and
blowing them up to horrific proportions
but in this case
it was a concern of the time of the 90s
that was already blown out of proportion
in terms of the pop culture media so
blowing it up even further just doesn't
work really and then yeah just kind of a
booth number nine new moon rising it's
not so much that this episode is awful
in and of itself but what it is is a
really lousy send-off for the character
of Oz and it's frustrating because it's
the episode where they brought him back
after he'd been gone for a while so it's
not even a case of he got a lousy
send-off he had an OK send-off before
this was their chance to give a proper
you know sense of closure resolution to
the character and it just it doesn't
really do that he kind of comes back and
he seems to have it under control but he
kind of doesn't and then he leaves again
and that's kind of it it's just kind of
a weird it's the sort of thing we're
like this you you you got him back you
this fan favorite character we haven't
seen in a while and aren't really gonna
see again outside of like a little
glimpse of him and restless the dream
episode and you brought him back and to
tell this story really you thought this
was worth bringing him back you thought
this was the payoff that that fans
wanted it just it felt obligatory it
felt like they brought him back because
they'd left the door open to the
possibility that he might come back to
like I will bring back ones and then we
can just be done with him that's just
the feeling the vibe of the whole thing
like said not necessarily a terrible
episode in and of itself but just the
the hollowness of it it's just yeah for
what should have been a fun triumphant
character return it's just kind of
nothing number eight
living conditions this is an episode
that should have worked this was second
episode of season 4 where Buffy and her
roommates start grating on each other
until eventually she finds out her
roommates a demon and they start trying
to kill each other
again I've mentioned this already it's
playing to what you what had been
working in Buffy up to that point which
was taking problems that the characters
of the age that that these characters
that that people's the age of these
characters have and you blowing them up
with horror tropes but for some reason
it doesn't quite work here I think in a
lot of ways it shows the stumbling
nature of what the fourth season was
where okay she graduated high school
what do we do never go to college I
guess but you know what college problems
they don't feel that much different than
high school problems so after you know
the graduation and literally blowing up
the school we're just kind of dealing
with what in many ways feels like reach
yeah yeah I know this specific issue
wasn't dealt in earlier seasons but like
that this whole approach to you know uh
teenage problems just feels like the
show should be moving on from it and it
does eventually you know season five and
so forth it does move on from that but
season four it's big stumbling thing was
not knowing how to move forward without
also rehashing older stuff and it kind
of just flopped around a bit as a season
and this episode just kind of
exemplifies that in a lot of bit in a
lot of ways it's trying to be slightly
different but it's not different enough
and it feels like maybe maybe the show
should have ended with the with the
destruction of that school because if
this is all you've got I'm not sure it
should he kept going like I said
thankfully got better but this was the
kind of episode where it's like boy how
much mileage is left number six
real me so this was our first dawn focus
episode this was before we renew what
her deal was we just knew she was there
and this was this was a very clear
attempt to try and sell dawn to the
audience as a character um get us to
understand who she is and it does that
but she's not endearing
she's frustrating and annoying and I
actually do kind of like Don as a
character by the time the show was over
but man when it when she first showed up
and and especially this episode words
it's focusing on her and it's from her
perspective and it's putting so much
time and effort into here let us give
you this character so that you can come
to enjoy her and by the end of it I'm
like I appreciate the effort but I just
don't number six
gingerbread I have a hard time
pinpointing what it is about this
episode that just rubs me the wrong way
I think it's just the it's the extreme
of it I suppose just it it's one of
those cases where taking something that
was a real-world ish problem and sort of
blowing it up just made it it
overstepped like when you have you know
Joyce getting ready to kill her own kid
I'm like I'm not buying this and then
beyond that like the whole thing with
you know the scare of you know witches
and we should burn them and everything
else it also feels about a decade behind
the times because I mean at the time the
thing aired it's not like that stuff
didn't exist I mean I played Magic the
Gathering I remember the hug the uproar
people had about that cuz there was
there were car cards with the word
demonic in them I still got my demonic
tudor cards I should see if those are
worth money but you know and so that
stuff was around at the time this
episode aired but its heyday had been in
the 80s you know the satanic panic and
you know all these words about lyrics in
songs and this belief in that there were
satanic cults out there but you know
while the sort of stuff was lingering by
the 90s and when this episode aired it
was passed and and a bit like when with
I I Robot you Jane it's taking something
that is already overblown and then
trying to blow it up even bigger and it
just just it doesn't
work when the show did that it worked
when it when it would take something
fairly mundane but that feels like a big
deal when you're young and in high
school of blowing that up so that it
actually is a big deal but taking
something that is already over blown out
of proportion in the first place and
trying to build on that it doesn't work
and it didn't work here number five
first date this is another one that's a
little hard for me to pinpoint exactly
what it is about this episode I don't
like but it's just there's just so
little going on and it's not interesting
and it's not going anywhere and it's and
it it it feels like a second season
episode stuck in the middle of season
seven and it feels like filler it feels
like the ultimate epitome of crap
we need another episode this season of
what can we do some of our characters
right now let's have a first date
episode and and we got this I guess it's
hard for me to articulate cuz this is
one I've gone out of my way to not watch
again cuz I I remember watching you just
be like what is this why is this can we
stop now
it's just regressive and and it's
another one of those cases where it
feels like it they're reaching back for
stuff that the show had moved on from
because even though you're trying to
frame in in like adult first dates first
date problems feels like season 2 season
3 maybe season 4 kind of issue this
season 7 this last season we're supposed
to be closing out why are you doing this
number 4
teacher's pet yeah the the big old
mantis teacher thing and I signed note
this real quick well I'm not gonna bring
up the fact that like there was a
cliffhanger that was never resolved
because then I didn't no one ever felt
like I've seen that show up on write-ups
for the show or whatever like no it
wasn't there to be something to be
picked up later it was there because
they were riffing on the kinds of or you
know teenage horror stories that usually
ended like that not so that you could
have a sequel because that's how the
things tend to Dan so that doesn't count
against us but I mean the first of all
that this was a case of the the creature
concept was an overreach of their
budgetary capabilities and also you know
you know just big bug giant mantis not
particularly creative I I get annoyed
when shows you know have the possibility
of presenting us basically anything and
they just give us a big version of a
thing that already exists that's just
boring to me but even beyond that you
know the whole concept of like who and
now Xander's gotta be tempted and there
will be frictions like she likes me and
you don't know yelling it well it's like
it was so predictable and I think that
was its that's its biggest sin more than
anything else although the other stuff
doesn't help but it is just so beat for
beat note for no predictable from start
to finish you can plot out basically the
entire thing as soon as it starts and
which makes it boring on top of
everything else
number three doublemeat palace this is
one where part of its problem is well I
would say a big part of its problem is
placement within the show dealing with
first with having a crappy first job is
the kind of thing that is good for Buffy
to tackle but it's tackling it in season
six after Buffy lost her mom and and in
a really amazing very somber affair and
you know we're still picking out the
pieces from that and we have this weird
jokey episode where she goes to work for
a weird fast food chain and feels like a
jackass being there and is humiliated
and there's some stuff we are going on
there and again and again it's it feels
like the show is regressing it feels
like it should have been a season three
or four kind of episode and I think in
many ways that it they kind of the show
kind of paid the price for not having
had Buffy get a job up to that point
because now that
mother was dead she had to and they and
they probably went eed they either went
oh maybe there's a story there or they
went ah crap
we got it we got to make a thing out of
this now when is something that really
should have happened before she should
she should have had a crappy summer job
like in one of the earlier seasons and
you know so that we could get that out
of the way at this point again it just
feels like something the show should
have either done sooner or just not
bothered to be doing at the point at
which it's doing it it's placement in
the show overall and within the season
it's just it just kind of lands with a
thud number 2 Go Fish is another one
that would just be generic if it wasn't
for its placement within the season this
is the last episode before the
two-parter that ends season 2 now season
2 had angel go evil and had what I did
in my best list had that two-part season
finale best thing the show ever did but
right before we're gonna have this
completely divergent episode dealing
with these these swimmers turned into
fish people okay and taking completely
unto itself it's just kind of dull and
boring slightly obligatory because the
early on the show kind of went through
you know well we do vampires we got to
do our version of all werewolf we got to
do our version of Frankenstein we got to
do our version of zombies and now here's
our version of The Creature from the
Black Lagoon so it already feels very
obligatory by its nature but then
placing it where they place it instead
of like giving us even more better
stronger build up to this amazing finale
where we're stopping to do this really
it's the epitome of the kind of episode
you just skip over when you rewatch and
number one worst episode for Buffy folks
who are hoping for a rant along the
lines of when I did my worst Moffat
written episodes of Doctor Who you can
keep your expectations in check and
check because as bad as this episode is
it doesn't make me that angry but let's
talk about income mummy girl
this is just a case where nothing works
like the the concept doesn't work the
show can't seem to decide how we're
supposed to feel about this girl herself
and I think it's trying to be like
tragic like she doesn't want to do this
but she has to but they're not balancing
that right and when she's talking to
anybody other than Xander she's not
showing any sign remorse and so we're
not getting a proper sense of torment
from her cuz she doesn't even have a
problem killing anybody else
and then she does eventually lunch for
Xander and so there was a chance to have
a real torn moment there and we don't
get it the effects aren't great
we've got Xander sort of falling for
somebody that's liable to kill him again
that by this point it was becoming a
rather regular repeated thing because
we'd already had it in the first season
would teachers Pat which already talked
about that one wasn't good either so
here we are retreading something that
wasn't great the first time around and
just the the pacing and the structure
it's it's weird and it's boring and it's
dull and it there's no tension in it and
she's not interesting as a character and
lays it just this is an episode where
just nothing worked there there's no one
element like all this stuff but that
that one thing there is that like no
there's just nothing like nothing it's
not like everything is awful it's just
nothing's good there's nothing good
about this episode the the setup is
trite the character is dull the
progression is boring and a retread of
something we already had it's just not
good so oh there's my list my thoughts
for what I think are the 10 worst
episodes of Buffy the Vampire Slayer a
show that I love but we always have to
acknowledge the faults so what are your
thoughts for worst episodes of Buffy
whatever they are drop something down
the comments let's talk about it there's
all that stuff you can do support me on
patreon
buy a t-shirt follow me on Twitter
blah-blah-blah-blah-blah
links for all my other projects and all
that stuff I mentioned are all down in
the description so until next time
Council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]